بالفعل ما ان وصلت هذه الطائرتين
المحملتين الاولى بخبراء من مختلف
التخصصات سواء كانت طبيه او الاغاثيه
وايضا فريق لمختصيب مركز الملك سلمان يقيم
الاوضاع والحاجه الى مساعدات اكثر ونوعيه
هذه المساعدات بالاضافه الى الطائره
الاخرى التي حملت عدد كبير من المساعدات
اللوائيه والغذائيه والطبيه وكافه انواع
المساعدات التي تم تنسيق مع الجانب التركي
حيالها بالاضافه الى ذلك ما ان وصل هذا
الوافد السعودي حتى بدات الاجتماعات مع
الافاد وهي الجهه التركيه المنظمه لعمل
كافه المنظمات الاغاثيه
للاتفاق على كيفيه
واماكن وجود هذه الفرق خصوصا وانه خلال
هذه الساعات ربما ساعات القليله القادمه
يتوقع ان يتم وصول الى اضنه عدد كبير جدا
من المعدات والاليات التي ستستخدم في
عمليات البحث والانقاذ وهي معدات للدفاع
المدني السعودي بالاضافه الى تواجد عدد
كبير من خبراء الدفاع المدني السعودي
المختصين بعمليات الانقاذ وعددهم اكثر من
50 سيبداون
بالتواجد يوم غد مباشره لاستعدادا لوصول
هذا العدد الكبير من الخبراء والعدد
الكبير ايضا من المعدات
للبدع فعليا بعمليات البحث والانقاذ
مباشره في الاماكن الاكثر تضررا بالاضافه
الى ذلك كان هنالك اجتماعات موسعه
لمركز الملك سلمان مع عدد من الاطراف
وتحدثون عن الجانب السوري لعمليه ايصال
هذه المساعدات الى الداخل السوري وهنا
نتحدث عن المفاضله ما بين المعبرين سواء
كان عبر انطاكيا او حتى غازي عنتاب
والدخول الى سوريا مباشره وربما خلال
الساعات القليله القادمه مباشره ستصل هذه
المساعدات عبر متعهدين ومنظمات ومؤسسات
اغاثيه سيتم ادخال هذه المساعدات مباشره
الى سوريا عبر هذه المنافذ اذا المركز
الملك سلمان يعمل وفقه اليه متبعه لبعد
بالتنسيق مع الجانب التركي وايضا الجهات
العامله في سوريا على اغاثه المتضررين